daily wire has this report the
Department of Defense uh could drop
nearly $270 million in taxpayer funds to
further the diversity Equity inclusion
and accessibility Dei agenda from fiscal
years uh 2022 to 2024 the the do has
scaled up its spending on
deia in the
past de
deia what's the a oh accessibility so
we've added a I didn't even know we did
that so we added this is a big moment
we've added a uh so we're going to do so
with Dei we're going to do the same
thing we're doing with LGBT so you take
any of these initialisms they just can't
the left they can't help but they just
keep adding to them so we've got Dei now
it's
deia um and spending jumped from 68
million in fiscal year 2022 to
86.5 million in fiscal year
2023 then the figure surged another 28.2
million to 114 million
in the Department's initial request for
fiscal year 2024 the dod's initial
request for deia funding is included in
the final legislation the department
will if it is rather the department will
have spent
$269.00 million on diversity initiatives
across fiscal years 2022 23 and 24 which
is an average of almost $90 million per
year so this is what uh the pentagon's
up to this what the Department of
Defense is up to and you know it's good
news as always um even as the
administration seems dead set on getting
us involved in every possible foreign
conflict even as we Face the possibility
of World War World War III um even as
our country is run by these uh uh
globalists who want to have us traing
all over the world and policing the
entire world we are at the same time
actively
weakening our military actively making
it less powerful and weaker and more
feminine
and focusing on everything that we can
besides making it a more effective
fighting and killing Force which is what
the military is supposed to
be and the people in the military you
know they they signed up to serve their
country and instead they get Dei
lectures and what makes
it I mean there are a lot of very
obvious reasons why this is troubling to
see in the military but one of the worst
things about it is that you've got I
mean literally a captive
audience it it's I mean it's bad enough
when you have this in the corporate
world but at least you could leave your
job it' be difficult finding another job
that doesn't have all this stuff but you
can leave your job in the military it's
like not nearly that
easy and so you are helplessly subjected
to
it and the indignities don't stop there
by the way uh there's another there's a
video that went viral yesterday that um
has nothing to do with Dei but it does
have everything to do with the way that
our government treats the military and
the people that signed up to serve the
country so this is a guy uh in the Army
this is a soldier leaving the service
and revealing how when he went to turn
his gear in they charged him
$4,000 that he had to pay them he had to
pay the government for gear that was
lost but it was lost not because he lost
it himself he knows where it is it's in
Afghanistan because he was told by his
superiors to leave it behind and then
they charged him for it anyway it's just
like it's Flatout
extortion this is the the thank you that
he gets for serving his country let's
watch a little bit of that video I want
to share something with you guys today I
want to holler I want to scream I want
to
yell but it won't do any good
um today is gear turning in day for
me turn in all the gear that I've
collected over the last four years of
being active duty with the army with the
82nd Airborne
Division two years ago my unit deployed
to Afghanistan for the Afghanistan
withdrawal we spent a few weeks over
there it was hectic it was chaotic it
was
disgusting and it made me very
disappointed in our government
today I'm reminded of how disappointed I
am in our government
go to turn in my gear they want to
charge me $500 to $1,000 for gear that I
was ordered to leave in Afghanistan two
years ago because as the last two birds
were sitting on the tarmac ready to
leave there wasn't any room for extra
gear or extra weight therefore we were
told to leave it some lower enlisted
dudes including myself were like no this
stuff is expensive I'm not leaving this
I'm going to get charged for this when
when it comes time to leave don't worry
we're going to catch you on the back end
you know we'll flipple
it
now it's time to get out of the army and
they just want to they want to charge
you for for that meanwhile so then the
video ends with him showing his final
bill I mean it's for those served in the
in the there's a lot of uh a lot of
comments to this people that were in the
military not at all surprised by this
and saying yeah this is what they do to
you um those of us who do not serve it's
like actually surprising what do you
mean you have to pay they give you a
bill when you leave that you have to pay
what the
hell um which is which should be crazy
regardless but in this
case when they tell you to leave it
behind then they charge you for leaving
it behind I mean like I said it's
extortion this is just
extortion and um and he the video ends
with him showing the bill that he got
and it it tallied up to about
$44,000 you know using the internet
without expressvpn it's like walking
your dog in public without securing them
on a leash most of the time you'll
probably be fine but what if one day
your dog runs away or gets dognapped
it's better to be careful especially
when it's as simple as using
expressvpn every time you connect to an
unencrypted Network in cafes hotels or
airports Etc your online data is not
secure any hacker on the same network
can gain access to and steal your
personal data Express BBN creates a
secure encrypted tunnel between your Dev
device and the internet so they can't
steal your data expressvpn works on all
your devices such as your phone laptop
tablet and even on your smart TV I love
how easy expressvpn is to use just fire
up the app and click one button to get
protected your data is your business
visit expressvpn.com
wallow use my Link at
expressvpn.com walow to get three extra
months free that's
expressvpn.com Walsh show you know I
have to admit this I I mean I hate to
admit it but a few days ago um I was
actually talking to my to my son who's
who's only
10 and you know we have a lot of
conversations about what he wants to do
when he grows up and he has a lot of
different ideas you know as kid this
typical of of kids of course and his
latest thing that he told me very few
days ago is that he wants to be uh he
wants to be in the Army he wants to be a
soldier and uh you know these tents
he'll probably change his mind in two
seconds anyway but I actually dissuaded
him uh you know from from from that um I
did not say oh that's yeah you should
definitely do that that's great now I
mean 10 years ago if you had told me
that I would actively try to dissuade my
own sons from joining the military uh I
would not have believed you or if I did
believe you I would have assumed that
that manant I had gone insane and turned
into some full-on full-blown
lib but well I might be insane but I'm
not a I'm not a lib and yet I dissuaded
him gently of course it's not like I
said no son of mine no son of mine will
do that I didn't say that we just kind
of talked about it very briefly and it
wasn't a big deal and I sort of
redirected him and uh and we moved on
and you know if someone had heard that
conversation it wouldn't have sounded
like a b it wouldn't have sounded like
some sort of really serious talk we were
having but to me it was kind of a big
deal because it was uh sort of the the
final moment where I really officially
realized that I don't want my own Sons
join in the military I don't want them
to serve their country I
don't um how could I at this point do I
want my sons to now if they become
adults and they decide they want to do
that and that's what they do of course
I'll support them and I'll be uh proud
of them
for um for pursuing that that goal but
do I want my sons to sign their lives
away where they'll be subjected to this
like Dei woke indoctrination and be
powerless against
it did do I do I want that for them
would I recommend it
no like do I want them to be in a
position where they're gonna where
they're going to have this crazy
left-wing indoctrination and they can't
do anything about
it do I want them to potentially be sent
off to die on foreign soil in defense of
some foreign
nation that has nothing to do with us a
country they've never been to and don't
care
about at the behest of a of of a bunch
of corrupt soulless
bureaucrats I don't want
that I respect people who join but I I
feel the same way about it as I do about
the
police um I if my any of my kids said
they wanted to become police officers I
would say again if you're an adult I
can't stop you but don't do
that um not because I hate the cops but
because I don't want my own kid to sign
up for a situation where he will be
tasked with enforcing the law but then
also told that if he tries to enforce it
he might go to
prison I would be terrified of that my
kid sign up to be a cop at this point
and that's another one that you know
years ago if you had told me that as a
father I would not want my own son to be
uh uh if they told me they wanted to be
in law enforcement I would try to
persuade them not to I I would I
wouldn't have believed you if if you had
told me that 10 years ago
but but I I would know that they'd be in
a situation where you know I if if if
they have to enforce the law they could
go to prison for
it so it's a lose lose situation I don't
want my kid signing up for a lose lose
situation and the military is the same
kind of thing now a lose lose situation
in a lot of
ways it shouldn't be but it
is and um I can tell you one thing I'm
certainly not the only parent who and I
I don't mean leftwing I'm talking about
I've talked to many conservatives who
have kids who feel exactly this way
about
it and that's a problem because we also
need cops and we need the military but
as parents we look at the state of these
institutions not because of the rank and
file that sign up for but because of the
people leading it and we look at that
and we say I don't want my kid anywhere
near
that talk about a loser situation it
creates a Los situation for the
country
um and there's just no there's no happy
uh ending to it I don't know what to say
if You' like to see what else I have to
say you can access my full show by going
to dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wall Show Twitter page hope to see you
there Godspeed